the first live action justice league was
always going to feature lots of plot
development to properly establish a team
up between dc
comics legends but with this four hour
run time zack snyder's justice league
is jam-packed with world building
heading into its final act
isn't that right batman
here's the ending of the snyder cup
explained zack snyder's justice league
is not short on story the film
establishes the individual worlds of
newbie superheroes like cyborg
aquaman and the flash while also
depicting a world still reeling from the
demise of superman at the end of batman
vs superman dawn of justice
in these earlier scenes snyder and
company established the personality
traits of our superhero protagonists
that will end up being crucial in the
film's climax
for example we're introduced to a
forlorn cyborg still unsure of what to
do with his new robotic enhancements
barry allen meanwhile is stuck doing
dead-end jobs to help pursue a criminal
law degree so he can get his dad henry
out of prison
the individual members of the titular
justice league have very different
personal problems to work out
however a recurring trait across cyborg
and aquaman's storylines is a lack of
interest in working as a team player
despite those doubts all of these heroes
are forced to work together once
steppenwolf begins assembling the mother
boxes to destroy earth it's a threat so
intimidating that the team decides to
use one of the mother boxes to resurrect
superman
a figure powerful enough to help defeat
this otherworldly entity by the time the
finale begins the justice league is
headed off to russia to confront their
cosmic enemy and superman has come back
to life and is regaining his personality
by sharing tender moments with lois lane
will this epic resurrection pay off in
the end
it has to every member of the justice
league has a critical role to play in
the final confrontation against
steppenwolf
and barry allen is no exception in order
for cyborg to access
the trio of mother boxes he'll require a
shock of electricity that can only be
generated by the flash running at an
incredibly high level of speed while
engaging in that kind of run the flash
is shot down by a parademon soldier with
our hero briefly knocked aside darkseid
and his forces are given enough time to
activate the mother boxes and destroy
earth but just as the planet is being
annihilated the flash decides to break
his one rule and run so fast that he
ends up going back in time
it's a risky mood that the superhero
isn't sure he'll be able to survive but
he has no choice if he wants to save the
world while running at such an extreme
velocity the flash remembers his
father's remarks that his son was the
best of the best and barry realizes that
he's finally lived up to that moniker
in the end his daunting run pays off
enormously as time has turned back just
enough so flash can give cyborg that
electrical boost thus cementing the
world's safety
however it also gives barry allen the
revelation that he is indeed capable of
traveling through time
an ability that's gotten the character
into plenty of trouble and comic book
story lines like flashpoint much like in
the theatrical cut of justice league
zack snyder's version sees superman
returning from the dead
briefly turning evil and then restoring
his original personality just in time to
stop steppenwolf from destroying earth
in snyder's version though the
transition takes longer to happen the
biggest deviation between the films is
an extended scene in zack snyder's
justice league depicting superman
returning to his fortress of solitude
before he reunites with the justice
league the resurrected kryptonian walks
around the halls of his lair while the
voices of his two fathers
jorel and jonathan ken speak to him
about the importance of pursuing who he
wants to be
by the end of the sequence superman is
wearing a black version of his
traditional superhero suit and he flies
away ready to join the justice league
when he does he manages to get there
just in the nick of time
steppenwolf's axe is about to land on
cyborg when superman intervenes
using his super powered breath to turn
the axe into ice superman makes his
powerful presence apparent
and he and steppenwolf proceed to have a
duel this confrontation ends with
superman pinning the beast to the ground
and punching him repeatedly
superman returned to this world unsure
of where he stood or who he was
as he fights steppenwolf for the good of
humanity it becomes apparent that the
man of steel has become the protector he
was always meant to be
in the final battle against
steppenwolf's forces cyborg takes it
upon himself to disconnect the three
mother boxes thus preventing earth's
destruction
his ability to tap into any piece of
technology means he has the best chance
of dismantling these objects and foiling
steppenwolf's plan
wonder woman makes it apparent though
that there is a risk to this while
cyborg is tapping into them the mother
boxes will exploit his fears in an
attempt to stop him and that's just what
happens once cyborg gets inside the
mother boxes and sees a vision of his
parents
silas and eleanor they stand there with
a fully healed version of cyborg and
urge their son to stop fighting
it's a scenario designed to tap into
cyborg's insecurities and stop him from
disconnecting those mother boxes
but our hero isn't backing down now
cyborg continues his mission with the
help of his justice league comrades
the young man who once sat in his
apartment alone and unsure of where he
fit in this world has now come to accept
his new form
his new friends and his new purpose on
the planet it's also a sequence that
fulfills earlier rumors that cyborg
would be getting a much greater
spotlight in zack snyder's justice
league
all of the members of the justice league
have a bone to pick with steppenwolf
given that he's keen on eradicating the
planet they call home
however wonder woman develops her own
personal animosity with this apocalypse
resonance after an intense mid-movie
interaction
here steppenwolf reveals that he
slaughtered many of wonder woman's
amazonian allies in his pursuit of the
mother box that was once held on the
island
enraged at the thought of themaskira's
finest warriors dying at his hands
wonder woman's quest for revenge against
steppenwolf is initiated
once a final battle arrives wonder woman
leads aquaman and cyborg to a personal
confrontation
with steppenwolf here the alien once
again taunts wonder woman with how many
amazonians he's killed
all the while reminding her that she
could have saved them as she hadn't
abandoned her home for the world of man
enraged wonder woman begins to brutally
fight back against the villain and even
bangs her bracelets on her shield to
create an explosion that sends
steppenwolf spinning
eventually after the other members of
the justice league join in to fight this
monster wonder woman gets her revenge
the final move that kills this minion of
darkseid is wonder woman slicing off his
head with her sword with a flick of a
blade wonder woman has honored the
memories of her fallen amazonian
comrades
zack snyder's justice league ends on
many teasers of things to come
with one of those involving darkseid
seen throughout the movie as the
intimidating superior and nephew of
steppenwolf darkseid has been
firmly established as someone you don't
want to cross this reputation is
reaffirmed in the film's climactic scene
which involves darkseid witnessing
steppenwolf's defeat at the hands of the
justice league
shortly afterwards his second in command
assad notes that he always knew
steppenwolf would fail
but despite this setback darkseid has
already got his eyes set on the future
now knowing that the anti-life equation
is built into the planet
darkseid intends to pursue earth again
this time with more extreme force
darkseid references the armada and the
old ways referring to an earlier
flashback that showed him leading a
massive army to destroy earth just as he
had done with thousands of planets
before
at the time he was stopped by the
combined forces of amazonians atlanteans
mortal men
gods and a green lantern warrior now he
intends to lead such an army again to
earth to face off against the newly
united justice league
as darkseid lurches out of frame in his
final scene in the snyder cut it becomes
apparent that this moment functions to
further solidify the ruler of apocalypse
as a formidable threat in a potential
justice league
follow-up zack snyder's justice league
concludes with an epilogue entitled a
father twice over the title refers to a
line said by silas stone to his son in a
pre-recorded message
where he mentions that through being his
biological father and giving him his
robotic enhancements he cyborgs father
in more ways than one
stone's monologue to his son about the
importance of pursuing your own path in
this world
plays over a month showing where all the
members of the justice league are in the
wake of defeating steppenwolf aquaman
meets up with meera and volkow who are
both
grateful for this half atlantean's part
in saving the world meanwhile bruce
wayne uses his enormous wealth to buy up
the bank that foreclosed on clark kent's
childhood farmhouse home
barry allen has also managed to score a
job at a crime lab in his home of
central city much to his incarcerated
father's delight
most importantly though is that wayne
buys up a building to serve as a
headquarters for the justice league in
their activities
complete with a large round table that
quote has chairs for six but room for
more
while the building and the table echo
the team's classic hall of justice
location
and the reference to the group expanding
its roster in the future is an
acknowledgment of how so many dc
superheroes have come and gone from the
justice league in the comics
zack snyder's justice league concludes
with a trio of stand-alone sequences
that help to set up future adventures
for its principal characters the first
of these scenes is one that will be
familiar to anyone who saw the
mid-credits sequence in the theatrical
cut of justice league the rendezvous
between lex luthor and deathstroke is
retained here and begins like it does in
the original version with an arkham
asylum guard discovering that luther is
broken out of his cell we then cut to
deathstroke emerging onto the
billionaire's yacht which is where the
snyder cut differs from the theatrical
version originally this sequence
revolved around luther hinting at the
formation of the legion of doom
to put it plainly
shouldn't we have a league of our own
here luther calls upon deathstroke who
harnesses a grudge against batman to
divulge the news that gotham's dark
knight is actually bruce wayne
it's info that gets the grizzled
deathstroke to smile and announce that
there's reason to celebrate
apparently this whole scene was meant to
serve as a setup for ben affleck's
proposed solo batman movie which would
have seen deathstroke serve as his
principal antagonist but in the years
since his post-credit scene was filmed
things have changed drastically for
batman's big screen plans
we know that ben affleck's character is
returning for the flash but past that
we're unsure of what's in store for the
caped crusader
especially with robert pattinson running
around however this initial tease has
been restored in zack snyder's justice
league to offer fans a taste of what
could have been
and hopefully what can be again the
second of the snyder cuts closing scenes
returns to a familiar locale from batman
vs superman dawn of justice
batman's nightmare landscape this
particular voyage to the
post-apocalyptic location sees batman
joined by a gaggle of companions
including justice league members flash
and cyborg mira
deathstroke and jared leto's joker the
scene begins with mira discussing her
desire to murder those responsible for
killing aquaman before asking batman how
he could possibly know what it's like to
lose a loved one this leads to a chat
between joker and batman with the former
goating the dark knight over the loss of
his parents
to retort batman recalls how he held a
dying harley quinn in his arms while she
said to kill the joker
these conflict-ridden allies are
suddenly greeted by a figure from
batman's previous nightmare experience
an evil twisted version of superman now
working for darkseid this superman fires
laser beam blast from his eyes at the
team before bruce wayne suddenly awakens
in the present day from his vision
not only does this closing sequence
follow up on threads and characters from
prior dc eu movies but it's also a
glimpse at what zack snyder once
envisioned for the franchise's future
according to snyder justice league 2
would have been largely set within this
nightmare landscape while that follow-up
remains an unlikely proposition this
closing scene in the snyder cut offers a
glimpse of what could have been
with zack snyder's justice league die
hard fans of the dc eu
finally get to see harry lennox's man of
steel character calvin swanwick reveal
himself as the superhero martian
manhunter fans had long suspected
swanwick's identity and the rumor was
finally confirmed by snyder in 2019
however it seemed destined to become an
obscure what-if scenario but with the
release of the snyder cut the casting
became a reality this big reveal is
first realized in the movie through an
earlier moment where martian manhunter
takes on the form of ma
kent to encourage lois lane the
extraterrestrial superhero then returns
in the very last scene of the entire
film this sequence begins with bruce
wayne shaken awake from a nightmare
vision walking out of his house to see
martian manhunter floating above the
otherworldly hero notes that he and
wayne are both aware that darkseid is
not finished with earth with impending
doom on the horizon
as well as being inspired by the justice
league martian manhunter has decided to
engage in superheroics for the sake of
protecting this planet once again
the scene concludes with martian
manhunter telling bruce wayne that his
parents would be proud of him for
assembling the justice league and then
he reveals his name to the billionaire
it's a moment that not only pays off
swanwick's presence in previous snyder
dc eu movies but also sets up martian
manhunter as a potential participant for
any future dceu efforts
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one